and you can't happy that's returned okay
so they should you give your wrist and
by how you get that inside of this
dislike on the sword cut you keep your
hat and then the target on keep it up
get exposed to this know hey won't you
go elbow inside if you want to harm is
not like this no their energy gets
harmonized so it's very easy and you can
be culture to make it like this or you
do this in any audience you see the bats
for buying it now whoa elbow elbow stays
inside
so it's music fred-bat body mechanics
you're gonna use your ability trying to
sophisticated okay so we already spotted
these tricks the trick one and then
trick you okay now now this is also I'm
standing right on the line of the time
okay so you have a couple variations so
I moved out I moved back sir she comes
in and I was down this do that okay so
that's first
you can do other things too I'm offline
he said we're not yeah so as she is she
goes I will already move the constants
and so you can be on a new line
[Music]
no more stain on the line
elbow came out
so you gave that cheap grip that expose
the wrists
that what came out she tryst
so this is just a conventional wisdom
that two arms with way gives me enough
reaction time and a minimum anything
closer than not are not as safe as you
might think your so when you take and
you give the cheapest you shorten that
distance by half you see that and so
subconsciously you are diluting your
sense of mind and you're going to start
waiting for you're going to start
waiting for this range you see so your
work where do you want me to touch you
and you tell me not and you try to stop
okay see where are you ready to pick it
again you just say go okay say go stop
reading and touching that I'm going to
pick your face you better something
thank you see do you see so if I'm not
here now stay there you see that's the
200s and now I'm gonna pick your face
and you say go and don't you set your
face okay so this is crap it's crap for
my reasons
it's crap for integrity and authenticity
and you also 1018 await your chance to
reconcile the thrust the linear energy
that's coming in you don't you don't
deal with it you actually have a glass
here and then you go like this and I'm
not
you take care okay
or I'll fill the gossip so keep your
grip the motion is is here up circle and
it's what you do in the other arm too so
when you come around to the other arm
boom here so you can have two two built
in now
[Applause]
[Music]
so and I'm over into the semi her wrist
comes to the Entebbe you see that so I
don't have to go like this or here pull
it across see Tammy oh there it is you
see I'm using that and so I have to be
ready for it
[Music]
you shouldn't be that time what are we
working out go what's the other honey go
[Music]
Timmy Timmy throw it to the other half
don't weep boy don't reach for it find
it at the center line don't use the
outer deltoid of the second arm elbow
came outside your outer rim
[Music]
don't contest the Mack
couple outside
this Shepherd okay so what I do here
this has to check that underarm I can't
get over here that oughta not check so
she had to die he's gonna hit you see so
I have to check the other arm right and
see
and then the next check is the hip I'm
gonna get my hip in front of her
boom so heatedly when I see that I come
in here then the next check is this has
to be down again you close that or not
[Music]
so what what is already like ready to go
when you watch the video watch how many
times I'm catching you kids arm out of
the sky but then the other one other
guess whose fear makes people the other
way you see and you're sitting here you
can't get okay that's not how you get
out of the tent so you're here on your
entry you push through so you didn't eat
you okay see that so you get it in me go
and then you leave the extension in your
body and and you go it pulls or pushes
through and that's when this hand this
hand is just resting here you get the
medium you push through pull and now all
this animal but again they have the same
problem if you're like I can't
see but you that's where the training
push through